Y cómo interpreta usted este
ofrecimiento por parte del presidente
Putin como un gesto de buena voluntad o
como una forma de ganar tiempo también
en la batalla además es una propuesta
que viene sugerida por la iglesia
ortodoxa rusa que precisamente ha
avalado la invasión y la muerte de
ucranianos
Muchas gracias por la invitación en
primer lugar y yo creo que lo que estaba
buscando Vladimir Putin es demostrar el
valor que tiene la religión para su
discurso su gran narrativa que Ucrania y
Rusia y los ucranianos son los rusos es
un solo pueblo porque la probabilidad
del rechazo por parte de los ucranianos
de esta propuesta era muy alta hay que
tener en cuenta que 80% de los
ucranianos manifiestan que son ortodoxos
y la pelea de las narrativas Ha sido
también muy fuerte en el campo de la
iglesia la iglesia ortodoxa ucraniana en
el mayo de este año declaró su completa
independencia del patriarcado de
moscovia y precisamente el pedido del
patriarcoquerido que se conoce que es
muy cercano Vladimir Putin buscaba
tratar de mandar mensaje que la Navidad
es una ocasión más para poder decir que
ucranianos rusos son parte del mismo
pueblo eso precisamente porque fue
rechazado por Ucrania señor rubis que
hablemos de la respuesta por parte de
Ucrania un rechazo total a esta
propuesta y piden el retiro de las
tropas rusas de las zonas ocupadas esto
Qué impacto puede tener en el conflicto
en el plazo inmediato y en el mediano
plazo
bueno nosotros tenemos una situación
bastante interesante y si uno puede
hablar en estos términos sobre una
guerra que cuesta vidas de miles de
personas ya porque ambas partes están
hablando sobre la paz sobre la necesidad
de una tregua sobre necedad de terminar
con el combate pero cada uno por lo
menos hasta ahora está poniendo las
condiciones que a priorizaba y que no va
a ser aceptados Por otra parte y en este
caso la propuesta de Putin era destinada
para ser rechazada por los ucranianos
porque cada una de las partes está
mirando los combates de manera diaria
como una oportunidad o avanzar o no
dejar que otros avancen señor rubins que
muy puntual por favor Cómo interpreta
usted también ese pedido que también ya
había hecho previamente el presidente
Turco para este es el fuego Qué
necesidad tiene erdogan de entrar en
esta ecuación Y qué necesidad tiene
Turquía de ser partícipe de esta posible
tregua entre las partes en un principio
Turquía es un candidato muy bueno para
ser mediador en este conflicto porque
goza de confianza tanto de Rusia como de
Ucrania sin embargo simplemente la
voluntad de erdogan actuar así no es
suficiente necesitamos también buena
voluntad tanto de Rusia como Ucrania